eu era uma criança que não parava quieta
na carteira
os professores viviam chamando a minha
atenção e eu estava sempre viajando nas
minhas viagens mentais de sair da
imaginação fértil do dia em que uma
professora me chamou e disse
gabor aqui matéria que essa aqui eu
pensei que matéria eu não sei em que
planeta que eu tô que dirá que matéria
eu reprovei no ensino médio
porque eu não me concentrava não tinha
paciência de ler o enunciado sabe
aquelas pegadinhas anunciado
então eu sempre caía e quando você olha
uma criança inquieta o que esperar dela
o que essa criança vai ser quando
crescer
nós seres humanos enquanto a sociedade
tiramos conclusões e percepções do outro
por isso é comum a gente fazer esse tipo
de questionamento é o que ela vai ser e
tal
e quem foi a um dos autores que
identificou que nós fazemos essas
percepções sobre o outro nem essas
percepções é em relação à imagem em
relação à a tudo que nos cerca todos os
seres que nos cercam
foi o psicólogo carl jung o pai da
psicologia analítica em 1919 trouxe pra
nós o conceito de arquétipos e os
arquétipos nada mais são do que essas
imagens e esses pensamentos que já estão
pré concebidos no nosso inconsciente
coletivo
ele é um modelo mental um conceito que
fica lá no fundo no nosso imaginário e
de vez em quando a gente consulta ele eu
vou dar um exemplo porque é mais fácil
de explicar o que é arte o arquétipo por
meio de um exemplo os animais
quando a gente imagina um cachorro por
exemplo cachorrinho a gente associa com
abby amigável companheiro carinhoso é
fiel
essas são as palavras que vêm à nossa
mente
vamos fazer um exercício um exercício
aqui animal representa você
mentalize acabou o tempo esgotado
parabéns pelo pêlo longo exercício que
nós fizermos agora e agora vamos
analisar algumas pessoas alguns de vocês
podem ter pensado no leão sabe porquê
porque o leão está no nosso inconsciente
uma figura forte de poder um rei o rei
da selva uma figura que representa a
autoridade e liderança
quando a gente olha para o leão dá pra
imaginar aquela cena da escola este ano
da leoa correndo atrás da gazela e o
narrador falando daquela voz calma
naquela cena terrível
o leão pode comer até 35 quilos de carne
em um único dia
o selo mínimo respeita à área
só de olhar para esse animal já dá
aquele impacto né
já em por respeito à área também pode
ter vindo a mente de vocês porque ela é
um arquétipo que traz toda uma história
sobre superação sobre renascimento
a água é um animal independente é um
animal forte demais é um arquétipo de
força e é por isso que os estados unidos
por exemplo utiliza a imagem da águia
para fazer uma associação com a imagem
dele porque é bom se associar à carga
mas se vocês fossem fazer pergunta agora
pra mim qual animal eu escolheria para
me representar
eu diria que eu escolho o animal mais
fantástico do reino animal de toda
natureza que é o pato
agora vamos analisar o que culturalmente
o pai
tu está está na nossa mente como que ser
quer ter visto aí eu peguei alguns patos
famosos para a gente fazer essa análise
o primeiro é o patolino todo mundo
conhece o patolino e patolino na
descrição da wikipédia até dizendo que
ele alto de testável olha que bacana né
assim um conceito bem legal ele mesmo
não se suporta tudo bem o pato donald
parece um pouco mais simpático mas o
bicho azarado né então não são muito
positivos então deixa quieto vamos
começar a analisar algumas expressões
então que são usadas com pato caiu como
um ato um ingênuo vai pagar o pato
r não tava coisa não está boa por pato e
no meio empresarial no meio empresarial
o pato ele é uma referência de como não
ser
alguém já deve ter ouvido aquela
expressão né não dá pra ser go patton
mas eu vou contar uma história que
aconteceu comigo eu e as minhas irmãs
nos tornamos empreendedoras e se insere
então não são chamadas de vez em quando
para palestras e tal como este uma vez
fomos chamadas em uma universidade para
falar sobre a geração y é a geração da
internet os milênios coisa prá frentex e
o que aconteceu é desse painel junto
tinha outros designers minha irmã estava
no palco eles falando sobre o
comportamento dos profissionais das
organizações um deles disse olha mas o
que não dá pra acontecer é é um
profissional pato nem faz tudo mas não
faz nada direito
então o pato ele traz uma sensação até
de vulnerabilidade e nesse momento nessa
hora desse painel estava rolando lá
adivinha só o que estava estampado no
fundo o logotipo da nossa marca e vou
dar uma chance pra vocês adivinhar em
qual é o objetivo da nossa marca e não é
uma águia é um pato pato não é com um
design minimalista tudo mais né
as proporções áureas mas é um pacto deve
a minsk fixação essa proibição
nossa falou falou falou do pato
pois é eu não tinha e não tinha isso só
quando eu comecei a perceber que
existiam tantas coisas
é já preconcebidos sobre esse animal eu
fiquei curiosa e fui pesquisar fui
querer saber se realmente era aquilo
algo que está tão definitivo eu resolvi
questionar e aí eu me surpreendi de uma
forma que eu não esperava porque eu
descobrir que o animal
o pato ele voa ele nada ele anda ele
mergulha é quase inacreditável o que ele
faz
esse animal ele é multi potencial um
explorador aprende as coisas de uma
facilidade tão grande e é um bicho
curioso mas sempre buscando aprender
algo mais e aí eu lembro que quando da
minha fase adulta e eu fui fazer
faculdade eu descobri que aquela minha é
falta de tempo na verdade não era bem
uma falta de atenção àquela
hiperatividade era na verdade uma
capacidade de ser multi é atenções de
conseguir focar em várias coisas ao
mesmo tempo
meu pensamento era muito acelerado mas
eu gostava de muitas coisas eu fui
cursar relações públicas foi um
excelente aluna e assim que me formei
fui fazer uma pós mas precisa tomar que
atinge tal porque eu estava fissurado na
internet
e aí eu fui falar com o professor de
novos negócios que eu queria ser criar
um blog fazer produção de moda trabalhar
e desenvolver produtos fotografar editar
vídeos trabalhar com educação negociar
com marcas eu queria criar um negócio na
internet e mais uma coisa ainda eu não
tava sozinho eu queria que as mesmas
embolsaram junto nessa todas juntas
queriam fazer a coisa acontecer só em
gente o professor olhou para mim com uma
cara de susto ele estava assim parecia
que tinha visto um fantasma e eu acho
que ele pensou assim
coitado dos pais dela né porque ainda se
fosse ela só perdida judiação
mas é as irmãs ainda cuidado dos pais e
ele falou pra mim e debra é impossível
você ser essa todas essas coisas é
impossível
e outra coisa você tem que focar em se
especializar e outra coisa internet
também não vai ser tudo isso que está
imaginando me desculpa
só que ele não sabia que enquanto ele
falava que era impossível
nós já estávamos fazendo e eu me
identifiquei demais com o pato
quando descobrir que eles são capazes de
voar milhares de quilômetros todos os
anos para buscar ambientes melhores
o pato ele não está preocupado se ele é
o melhor ele não perde um minuto
pensando nisso ele só vai e faz é igual
àquele lema que a gente todo mundo
conhece aquele lema das startup é feito
é melhor que perfeito e os patos quando
eles estão fazendo essas viagens
migratórias
se ele chegou no lugar do ambiente não é
exatamente aquilo
o ideal para que a espécie se desenvolva
eles identificam super-rápido erro e
começa uma jornada do zero eles acabaram
de vir migrar cansados exaustos mas eles
vão lá retomam-se e embarcam numa nova
jornada
por isso os padres são corajosos
persistentes resilientes e versáteis os
patos
eles têm uma uma sensação assim questão
tentamos testamos não deu certo que tudo
bem vamos migrar tem problema e eles
utilizam da intenção às vezes a gente
não usa muito a nossa intuição e é tão
importante eles usam muito da intuição
para guiar as suas as suas decisões o
seu senso de direção e comunidade
quando os tempos frio chegam eles não
esperam passivamente até congelar
eles agem e essa capacidade de adaptação
incrível fez os patos dominarem o mundo
eles estão presentes em todos os
continentes
por isso eu acredito que um patton ele
tem um perfil de empreendedor
especialmente porque o pato ele arrisca
ele corre riscos
ele levanta vôo sem saber se ele vai
chegar no destino
ele nem sabe todas as turbulências que
ele passa no caminho ele não sabe nem se
ele vai chegar no final da viagem ele
arrisca sem garantia
ele é um empreendedor já que a gente
está falando de empreendedorismo a gente
fala também sobre liderança e aqui os
patos nos ensinam sobre a liderança e
sobe é compartilhar né então por exemplo
nas viagens eles utilizam o formato em v
que ajuda o outro pato a economizar
energia ea resistência do ar
assim eles conseguem se ajudar e esse
espírito de colaboração dos patos fez me
fez me reconhecer nele porque quando a
gente começou a trabalhar com a internet
a gente não chegava outras pessoas que
também estava com vontade de trabalhar
com a internet como concorrentes
estava todo mundo aprendendo então a
gente ela ensinava que a gente estava
prendendo porque a gente acredita que
colaborar é maior que competir ea gente
também acredita na gestão compartilhada
e os patos sabia que eles fazem quando
estão nesse vôo e ver se o pato que está
liderando naquele momento se fixa um
outro pato proativamente muda de lugar
com esse pato eles continuam a caminhada
o líder não precisa fazer tudo sozinho
isso me lembra também eu e as minhas
irmãs a abril a julho porque juntas
muitas vezes a gente passa por desafios
nessa jornada empreendedora e uma
cansada e outra lá e apoia e troca de
uma maneira proativa
mas talvez você não esteja convencido
ainda de que o pato é o empreendedor
então agora tenho certeza que vai se
convencer porque os fatos eles enquanto
estão dormindo desligam a metade do
cérebro ea outra fica ligada e é igual o
empreendedor que o pregador nunca dorme
por isso se alguém disser que você não
pode ser tudo que você sabe que pode ser
eu digo que você pode falar com essa
pessoa que você é um patrão e mais você
pode cruzar habilidades diferentes
aptidões vocações diferentes
aqui é algo completamente único todas as
mulheres que subiram nesse palco aqui
hoje elas são corajosas como os patos e
elas também são multi potenciais
isso porque elas podem ser especialistas
em algo grande empreendedora de sucesso
mas elas tiveram que desenvolver uma
nova habilidade para ir além
ela desenvolveu a habilidade oratória
para subir neste palco aqui e ensinar e
compartilhar e eu acredito que essa
habilidade de se adaptar rápido e
habilidade que todos nós vamos buscar
ainda mais nessa nova era aquele
vestígio de a isso aqui na minha função
não vai mais funcionar nessa coisa da
era industrial
nessa era da hiperestimulação ou de tudo
se transforma numa velocidade muito
rápida ea gente precisa se adaptar tão
rápido quanto os patos e é por isso que
eu ouso dizer que o pato é o
profissional do futuro e hoje eu não
tenho medo de compartilhar quem eu sou
eu não tenho medo de compartilhar as
minhas conquistas de sermos potencial e
esse esse palco de hoje foi inspirado um
artigo que publiquei no linkedin
eu tive coragem de falar sobre isso e
essa é a mistura de de talentos e
habilidades que eu tenho com comunicação
e as minhas irmãs têm um design e com um
concrete com criação fez com que a gente
criasse uma marca original onde por meio
de conteúdos e produtos nós eliminamos
propósitos e causas em bolsa tem um café
em um curso online tudo orna criamos uma
marca única
e aquela menina hiperativa hoje é
trabalha como uma comunidade ativa e
interativa de patos online e offline
e essa nova percepção que o trouxe aqui
sobre o fato de a gente entender que ele
na verdade não é um animal medíocre sim
junto às suas habilidades para
disseminar o seu conhecimento pra
atingir seus objetivos
eu mudei o pato
eu fiz ele voa mais alto eu fiz ele
nadar mais rápido não
a única coisa que eu fiz foi mudar a
minha visão do que ele é capaz e
provavelmente a sua também
essa tatuagem aí é da manuela fez depois
que eu meu artigo no linkedin e hoje o
pato que antes era um símbolo de
fraqueza é um arquétipo de força e é por
isso que essa palestra não é sobre mim
essa palestra então não é sobre o animal
apesar de eu achei fantástico essa
palestra é sobre você é sobre toda uma
geração que não se encaixa nos padrões o
que é certo do que é rápido isso é uma
coisa só a vida inteira é sobre mulheres
que são testadas e dúvidas todos os dias
é só pra você questiona suas habilidades
se questiona é importante você deve se
questionar mas nem precisa questionar se
o que pensam sobre você tire limita ou
te definir se você acha que pode atuar
a única recomendação que eu tenho para
te dizer é mergulhe nas suas paixões
na adi o quanto puder antes quando você
sente que precisa desacelerar
vou ir longe
o movimento se mostre se os o mundo
precisa dos patos
obrigada
[Aplausos]